I like that you know you're going around
the world now and you're meeting all
your fans and I guess there's two ways
you you can kind of go oh god this is
awful
or you can find ways to make it fun for
yourself yes and you have found quite a
fun thing to do when people ask you for
photographs explain what you do well
married couple comes up and they want to
take a picture and then jitan generally
it's the woman that wants to get the hug
and then they want me to push their
husband away so I'd do it but sometimes
it's the man and you know it's it's well
we've got some examples here you are
he's very exacting this this is just
tragic this next one because I feel like
he just got a girlfriend and he's
properly upset another one and oh look
at that
Oh beautiful check that out and this
last one is is kind of doubly cruel
because obviously she's killed a pet dog
I'm just pushing away when you sign the
photograph you side over it is ready
we thought might we create let's do on
yeah
so if you and Darcy just you willing to
be held at Who am I yes I'm the Lord so
your loving your loving Jason so you
just yes and then bill salt kicker Vegas
no no no hugs
[Music]
[Applause]
I think I've got a skull ring implanted
before it was the picture though there
you go
Darcy's never looks happier
[Music]